human beings and your labels so it's
Sunday that means Doctor Who and I'm
gonna talk about something that I didn't
think I would ever talk about but it was
something that has been I've seen come
up in comment sections and elsewhere
ever since the announcement of Jodie
Whittaker taking up the role of the
doctor and it's something that for
whatever reason I never felt like really
addressing before but I kind of want to
now so there have been people who have
asked possibly with sincerity possibly
facetiously trying to troll don't know
don't care
so prior to the doctor reincarnating at
I'm sorry not reincarnating regenerating
as Jodie Whittaker we infrequently saw
the doctor have romantic and sort of
Attraction leanings and they were always
towards women presumably the lineage
that led to Susan involved another woman
we don't know that for a fact but
presumably in addition to that we know
he had his relationship with rose we
have you know the attraction that he had
to River and various incarnations what
little sexuality has been granted to the
doctor all seems to point to
heterosexual so people have now started
asking well does that mean the doctors
gay now the answer is yes but only
technically and I'll explain that in a
little more depth but first since I'm
talking gender fluid topics let's swap
this look out there's something a little
better suited to the topic so on the off
chance that you're new to the channel or
or have only watched the Doctor Who
videos where I don't think I've actually
addressed this before I have a fluid
sense of gender I tend to go with queer
but my sense of myself male or female
doesn't stay put it wanders around and
I'll detail that a little bit more as I
go so in terms of what I said is the
doctor gay yes but that's only because
of how the language works and I know
this seems like a weird semantics that
I'm just breaking down the language and
the labels cuz I'm one of those people
who says you get language matters you
can't just deconstruct it and say it's
only words because words are the primary
thing we have to communicate with each
other but I'll explain anyways the terms
that we use to describe sexuality
homosexual heterosexual bisexual
pansexual and a ton of others
specifically when we get into the
heterosexual homosexual dynamic which is
where most this conversation is going to
revolve the term is not as descriptive
of actually two things because it's not
only describing what a person is
attracted to but it's just describing
what they themselves are because it's a
relative term so we don't have a term
while we may have but we don't use terms
just meaning attracted to female
attracted to male because of the terms
that we use also determine the starting
point the position of the person feeling
the attraction so saying that someone is
homosexual has no meaning unless you
know what the gender of that person is
because if it's a homosexual man that
means they're attracted to men if it's
almost sexual and means they're
attracted to women but if it's just a
homosexual person
well you're lacking half the information
so because the terms we use are relative
to a person's own gender identity in
addition to lumping that together with
who they're attracted to it's suddenly
we put a lot of weight and we get very
confused over things that actually
aren't that confusing
I will explain relative to myself in my
own experience because I do get the
question it comes up in the comments
every now and then here are you gay and
on the occasions that I answer that I
answer it in white and what might seem
an odd way because I never answer it
strictly yes or no I know what people
tend to mean when they ask me that
generally since I primarily present male
on this channel they're asking are you
attracted to men but I want to deal with
the word that they use which is are you
gay and the thing is if you have a fluid
sense of gender what does gay mean what
does homosexual mean so again to take
myself a pretty decent chunk of the time
I present and have a sense of myself
that is male that's how you've seen me
most the time on this channel I have
kind of a middle ground which you're
seeing right now I have other times
where I present and feel for myself
flat out unambiguously feminine now my
partner Liz who you may have seen on
some of the reviews and some of the
other videos she is a woman so I am
attracted to women and that's usually
how I answer that question are you gay I
said I will answer it by saying I'm
attracted to women because that's true
no matter what but because of the
language we use it's difficult for me to
use any of the other terminologies
because if my sense of self shifts if I
go from presenting completely masculine
to completely feminine am I a straight
man or would I be better considered to
be a gay woman now obviously I'm not
going through a full physical change but
and so in my case it's not a complete
one-to-one to the doctor because his
actual you know physical himself changed
in an instant and obviously that doesn't
happen with me for me it's an internal
sense of self in a shift but unless you
flat out reject the notion that someone
is capable of having a gender identity
that is not the same as their own fist
being then the question is still
relevant and it's why I always answer
I'm attracted to women because that
keeps it simple because otherwise it
gets stupid complicated it's like okay
well how do I answer that well at the
time that you're asking me I'm
presenting mail so I guess I'm answer
straight oh you're catching me at a
burlesque show where I'm presenting
entirely female oh God I guess yes I
suppose I would count more as gay now so
like it gets weird he gets bizarre but
the truth of the matter hasn't changed
my attractions haven't changed the only
has changed is me but who I'm attracted
to hasn't shifted in any way or to
compare it to something that the doctor
himself or herself might appreciate the
sonic screwdriver and before anyone
asked this is this is from kind of a
snap together you know do-it-yourself
kit there's different pieces you
assemble and then what have you but in
Dave the doctor they have the whole
thing with the war doctor the Tenth
Doctor the eleventh Doctor and they're
all in the cell and they talk about the
sonic screwdriver and how it's the same
device in a different casing that's
effectively what's happened to the
doctor he's the same device and a
different casing that Casey now happens
to be a woman why are we getting hung up
on how that changes the terminology of
the doctors attractions now at this
point I feel like I want to point out
that if I had my way we actually
wouldn't be I would like this to follow
on from what kind of happened with
Capaldi's era which is we're not dealing
with flat-out romantic attractions
anymore there was a little bit like with
him and River Song but and that was a
great deal of affection but if that was
about as close to romantic as he got he
was he was about as close to the more a
sexual doctor that we tended to have in
classic who more often than not so I
would personally like to see that
continue and just not even really have
attractions come up at all but if that's
not going to be the case then I think we
just assign a weird sort of thing to it
we're like oh my god now all of a sudden
the doctors game well no the doctor
hasn't fundamentally changed in in a
sense of what the doctor is attracted to
it's exactly the same so why would you
freak out and go oh god now all of a
sudden he's gay how do I explain that to
my kids but well don't like just if it
cut if by any reason it comes up in the
show at all just say well I mean the
doctor was attracted to him before the
doctor still is so that's how it is and
that's not for me to be trying to
undermine anyone who is taking any
solace in the idea that the doctor is
now potentially a gay or queer icon if
that is something that brings you
comfort I'm not trying to take that away
from you by all means have that but if
you're if you're someone who's just sort
of sitting there racking your brain
going I don't understand like it you're
overcomplicating in your head just
because the language we use and it's
language that tackles two things in one
blow but in the case the doctor only one
of those things has changed but the
language gets weird trying to
communicate that so sometimes we just
bump up against the limitations of the
words we use and sometimes we need to
step out of the labels because I I but I
have a very love hate relationship with
labels in general I find them helpful to
a degree but I have a but at the same
time a personal distaste for most of
them and I think oh that probably has a
lot to do with having grown up and
having an incredibly hard time finding
any that fit me but even after I found
some I basically just use them as a
shorthand because it's easier to drop a
label like gender fluid than to try and
and explain in more detail
what I am to someone who I'm just
meeting for the first time and is just
trying to wrap their head around me so
you know you use the shortcuts but
labels we get very antsy around them we
get very fidgety about things being
properly labeled and as long as you
understand what is behind that label you
know the character the person can we
move past the label and you know maybe
it'll come up if and when either the
cast the crew or the show itself ever
uses those terms gay bisexual straight
whatever if the show itself or the
people will make it bring those words
into the conversation basically open the
door to it well you know maybe I'll
address that at that point but I'm
hoping they don't because it's a it's an
area where we get weird and we have
hang-ups that are our own baggage or our
attempts to deal with the confusions of
just words it's just words so is the
doctor now gay yeah I said yeah
technically but so what the doctor has I
mean what was he alternative well whoa
people who are weirded out by the idea
that the doctor is now gay would you
really rather that the doctor now
expresses an attraction towards a male
character because that means you're
gonna be asking yourself when inevitably
at some point the doctor becomes male
again or even if the doctor stays female
forever you're now going to go back to
those earlier episodes and wonder wait a
minute was the doctor just like being
polite or was he actually into Jack did
the second doctor have a thing with
Jamie like is that what you prefer and
look this is not me saying that the
doctor can't be bisexual or pansexual
much
Jack himself is I think he's perfectly
capable of that we have keep she hi
silly these it depends on which doctor
I'm thinking about at the moment when I
use whatever pronoun I use but you know
that there's been no particularly firm
evidence of any attractions other than
to females so what I have been saying
you know the doctors tried to females
that'll stay the same that's based off
the evidence we have that is not being
exclusionary to all the other
possibilities cuz yeah I don't see any
reason not to and as far as how the
doctor herself would think of herself I
would think that a society in which
people can change their gender from you
know one point their life to another
that seemingly easily and for I
presumably for as long as regeneration
has been a thing one would think that
labels like homosexual an error and a
heterosexual probably either don't exist
or have lost all meaning to a culture
like the Time Lords that's me projecting
a little bit but I mean logically right
I mean if people can just switch back
and forth would you even bother trying
to label that anymore
I don't know so those are just sort of
my thoughts on the question that I see
still like I think this set made this
seventh day of recording I saw the
question come up again I'm like really
people still ask it fine let's talk
about it but there you go there's my
thoughts on the whole notion question
conundrum
whatever yeah so what are your thoughts
on all this whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's a bunch of stuff
that you can do to support or follow me
you know what it is I'll mention the
page on that is the big one but there's
links for that and a whole bunch of
other stuff it's all in the description
so remember folks you are the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]